so this was designed for being given in
front of a thousand people and it was
this morning but but we're gonna we're
gonna do it three and so feel free to
just treat it as a talk and shout
questions and we can we can go off the
rails that'll be fun I already gave the
talk once so um so I'm happy if you want
if something you want to want to go into
but yeah let's just start and we'll see
if if another person or two shows up but
yeah so the idea here is to is to look
at the significance of this particular
place in like of Oslo in the in history
of programming languages and so I'm as
I'm wondering if you've heard about
Christian new Gore yeah so so the joke
is that Christian ego is the Danish
football player who was very famous in
the 70s that's probably not who you're
thinking of though you're thinking of
this guy who was together with all Johan
Dahl who in who designed the similar
languages which the the general-purpose
one was is considered the first optical
and programming language ever and and
was and came out 50 years ago here so in
February of 68 so it's like it's like
what later turned out to be a
magnificent turning point in the history
of programming languages and of course I
don't
are you both in the region ok I'll do it
in English anyway you are - I know he'll
do it in English anyway because
otherwise I'll stumble but yeah you can
understand what's on the screen there so
so one of the things that that Kristin
said sorry I got a chance to hang out
with him a number of times when he was
alive and and he would often say you
were often quipped that if he had a
penny for every object that was ever
instantiated you know she could just
have every time somebody said new object
he could have got an opinion in his
account he would be a rich man I think
that's probably true
so this is sort of like the general
outline of of the languages that he
worked on there there was similar one
which was for how much do any of you
know any of this stuff
ready some of it yeah I think they still
teach it in Norway it's the only place
in the world where people's to learn
this stuff okay you you get you they
heard you all into the simulator
auditorium at the University and they
tell you why it's called that okay yeah
I've been there so you know they started
out he wasn't really a computer
scientist to begin with he was into
operational analysis and so he got this
idea that hey maybe you could use
computers and he had some ideas for how
to do it but he he wasn't like a
programmer he didn't have the skills to
to do this himself so he teamed up with
Oh Lu Han who was rumored to be one of
the sharpest knives in the in the Oslo
drawer at the time and and they they
went and did first a domain-specific
language just for simulating what they
call discrete event simulation for
essentially playing out different things
behaving according to rules over time
and seeing what happens simulation and
and that was what was called Simula one
it was based on on the programming
language alcohol at the time but then
after a while they realized wow these
are actually great concepts for
generalizing and using for other aspects
of programming and that's together with
some things that happened we will see
that they happened in in programming
languages elsewhere that gave them the
sort of the the bits and pieces to to
make it a general-purpose programming
language which became sumeul 67 then
Kristin also got very involved with the
trade unions and anger very he was very
into enabling the workers and giving
them a seat at the table and those kinds
of things that you know back in them
back in the early 70s you know we were
we we were all about empowering people
and and and not just letting the big
corporations exploit the workers and so
on he was very much into that I think he
was he was a member of the Workers Party
all his life and very involved with the
trade unions and one of the things so he
was he was able to kind of combine these
interests like his his personal ideology
with with the language thing because he
realized that the way that you wrote
in inseam early I was actually kinda
much closer to how people think about
things and and not just and further away
from just how computers happened to work
inside which is sort of very much a
geeky thing and so he so he together
with a few other people they actually
took the concepts and and designed a
language a complete language that
couldn't be run on computers that was
all about describing things in a precise
manner and that BQ that was what became
Delta which is upon on on both the Greek
letter Delta but also the word for
participate in Norwegian so this was
really the start of participatory design
what became object-oriented - synoptic
urine analysis - all those fields that
had their own separate life ever since
with you you've maybe seen some of these
design tools that have UML graphs and
all that kind of stuff rational rows all
and that all he didn't I don't think he
liked the graphic stuff very much he was
he he felt words were better better but
that all kind of came from from his
early work on participatory design as
well so there was another field that he
found it and he founded it with a
language but then he went and got new
friends he became a professor in in
August in Denmark and had lots of
students flocked to him he was like a
very charismatic figure and some of the
best students sought him out and and
they started a project together which
eventually he was in August in 1975-76
and it took them a lot of time and a lot
of red wine to finally come up with a
programming language or finish the
programming language and I'm told that
they were pretty exasperated with him
because he was in no hurry he did not
they had to meet deadlines and and
submit PhDs and feed their kids and you
know and he was just like he was happy
to sit around for days discussing all
the concepts and making sure that we
were we were viewing the big enough
picture and all that um did any of you
meet him by the way No
so anyway eventually a programming
language came out which was sort of a an
attempt to make a smaller more general
unified successor to to Simula it was
his idea that this was the language to
take over from seminal of course it
really succeeded in doing that so the
quick genealogy of programming languages
here alcohol was sort of like the it was
alcohol in at that time was like Java in
the 90s in the late 90s it was like the
language that everybody that drove all
the thinking except it was better yeah
it was a beautiful language for its time
that really introduced the ideas of
high-level programming languages and
structured programming and those things
so a lot of things derived from Algol
strong typing as well and Simula one was
it was a superset of that they added
features to Algol rather than create
their own language from scratch there
was a lot of there's this language that
never actually happened in a way an
unofficial version of alcohol that was
proposed for to be the next version of
alcohol that was made by two guys one of
them was and these guys later became
extremely famous on their own
almost Tony Hoare who invented all kinds
of things quicksort and axiomatic
semantics and one particular thing that
he invented and at this point was record
types reference referenced record types
where you had records that are you know
types that have a number of fields
inside with different types like structs
and C and the fact that you could
reference o you would reference them
indirectly with it there would be a
pointer inside right and you would
dereference you pass him around through
the pointer instead of copying the
values around
it's amazing that somebody had to invent
that but but that was that was where
that came out that was an alcohol ww
he wrote it together with Niklaus viewed
it was a Swiss guy and they proposed it
for the out to the elbow committee and
they said now that's not a big enough
advance and yeah and they went on to
create a complicated useless beast of a
version of Algol 68 that nobody thought
was a good idea and said no to these
things which of course turned out to
pretty much change the world of
programming even though the languages
elfin ever made viet just said well
screw Algol I'll go and make my own
language and anything went and made
Pascal which which essentially
eviscerated Algol from the world like it
took over from Algol it became the next
algo so there you know so if you're
right and but but these records that
with the references that was just a
thing that Kristen and and uh Luhan doll
that they needed to to generalize the
concepts of similar one and make it to
general-purpose programming language so
that idea along with the it's there were
sort of a hidden snake and paradise here
which was the fact that just for
expediency reasons Tony Hoare has talked
about this since this is billion dollar
mistake he said oh let's also invent a
null pointer let's make it so that the
default value of these references this
is null and you know a bad can it be and
it was easy to implement and and if you
think about how many in all reference
exceptions have been thrown since then
if if he had to pay a penny for every
null reference exception yeah he would
probably be a couple of billion dollars
in the short so so he calls it his
billion dollar mistake and that of
course was also adopted into not just
similar but every up you're going to
languages language since has had this
problem this snake in paradise okay so
let's actually look at some similar I
don't have did any when you look at
similar before no they they don't
actually make you read it in in Norway
anymore that's good because it's a
little modern standards it's a little
heavy to look at it's it's worse than
Visual Basic I want to say and that you
know we shall basic is very wordy so so
I so I came up with this dialect of
similar that I call Simula for the
purposes of this talk that it's just
sort of like a curly brace version of
the language with the same semantics and
same constructs I didn't actually like
come up with a whole language but I just
I just fudged something for the slides I
don't have a compiler or anything but
essentially here first to show that all
of the concepts have up you're going to
program and all the central concepts
were there it wasn't it was like we came
out fully formed it was
that you know languages introduce these
ideas one by one over time similar when
it came on the stage it had all it had
this whole new thing all there so it was
it was like a big big turn of events and
you know they had pet classes that was a
new concept they had classes had virtual
methods so that's an abstract procedure
here that in a class cliff classes
couldn't be abstract that's something
that came later so if you created a
glyph and you call print on it you just
get an exception but that's like a small
thing that that was easy for languages
to add later and then you can Dyck
subclasses right you could derive from
from the glyph they put it on they put
the the base class in front of the class
keyword and for that reason they call
this prefixing that they never talked
about sub classing or inheritance wasn't
even a word back then that was used for
this they just called it prefixing and
all the all the concepts and all the
words we know now came later it's just a
features were there right so so you
could prefix another class and that
means you get all the things that are in
that in that prefix class along with the
new stuff so yes we can make two derived
classes two sub classes and then we can
go and have have some reference
variables a single reference variable
and an array create new ones that has
new keyword and assign them into
variables and then call you know once
you've built up a little structure of
them then call the virtual print method
with the dot which is also like a new
thing at this side I don't know that
they invented the dot but it was right
around this time that people started
using the dot which is like the only
thing that almost all object-oriented
programming languages have in common you
know across widely different syntaxes
for everything else they all have the
dot except small talk small talk doesn't
but it's become this universal thing
across all languages somehow again from
here so so just just show that you could
write an op to your own program back
then just as well as you can today in in
c-sharp or
any other modern object on a programming
language I was pretty amazing and a big
big a big big contribution to two
languages but you could also do things
in similar that didn't catch on and that
didn't move into the mainstream that are
quite interesting and and some of them
it's a bit of a shame that they went
away some maybe not so much but one of
the one of the things that similar
inherited from alcohol was alcohol has
completely general block structure you
can just nest things inside other things
right but the only things you have an
alcohol are procedures
right so you can nest procedures within
other procedures within other procedures
like you like you can with functions in
JavaScript or with local functions in C
sharp or many functional languages also
have that general block structure but
for functions but stimuli had it also
for classes right so you can have
classes within classes within classes
and within procedures and you know you
can mix and match and it's like proper
nesting where the thing inside can see
the instance of the thing around it that
is part of so that does general block
structure and they use it quite a bit
for a program composition so that's an
example of it here they when they went
to stimulus 67 they still wanted to do
stimulus emulation but instead of having
the concepts of simulation hard-coded
into the language as a domain-specific
has two main specific constructs they
had now a the world's first application
framework called class simulation and so
here is a here's a tiny bit of class
simulation it's class um and it has
another class inside of it that's called
process it has several other classes
inside of it that are the things that
you use for simulation okay so process
is one process is the class it
represents something that is an
individually active object in a
simulation okay call that a process what
you and that's also a class but what you
notice is that this class here the
process class has code inside it doesn't
just have members it also has some
statements it doesn't matter what they
are it's just that they have some
statements that
stuff that all processes do because
objects don't just have things they also
do things in Simula which is quite
different from from what we got and
we've gotten used to since then and
because it's a base class for other
things it says the thing it has the
things in it that all things should
start L processors you start out doing
and should end end up doing at the end
and then it has a special keyword in ER
which says whatever code you put in in
the derived class should just go here
right when you derive from this the the
code that the derived class adds gets
executed at this point where the inner
occurs so that was a mechanism for for
inheriting across classes inheriting
code across classes and you can see that
the outer class simulation also has code
down here abbreviated it but it also and
it also has an inner so when you want to
go and simulate something like I'm doing
here I can prefix not just you can't
just prefix classes but you can also
prefix statements and say it's
inheritance essentially this this piece
of program inherits from the class
simulation in the sense that all that is
in there now now gets in scope of my
program so I'm now inserting myself into
the scope of the program and my code
goes into the inner of that class right
so so the whole simulation sets up the
way simulations the simulation framework
works then I get to write my main
program here the doctorate starts things
up where I'll probably start out some of
my some of the process specializations
that I've made like the worker here
which inherits from process and and does
some things okay so we have active
objects here for the first time and we
have this notion of inheritance for code
as well and come up here and that never
really made it into other programming
languages except for beta which Kristin
was in charge of so I thought I'd show
you that as well so some of the things
made it and some of the things didn't
but all the things that the major things
that came to
stitute optimum programming in the in
the next 50 years and I'm probably way
into the future what we're there
okay that's similar cool and questions
and just yeah yes and no it it doesn't
really let me move up again here it
doesn't really in the same sense you can
nest classes in c-sharp and you can in
C++ as well but that's just a scoping
mechanism that means that you can't you
have to dot in to get at the class you
can't see it from outside but in
simulate has a deeper meaning where if a
class is nested within another class
that means that it is nested inside of
instances of the class so the so the
process class here is a different
process class for one instance of the
simulation framework than for another
instance of the simulation framework in
that it can see the actual instance
variables of the enclosing object in
c-sharp you can't you can't see the
instance members of the enclosing class
when you're when you're nested so it's
important difference it's more like the
way that lambdas can see enclosing local
variables in a method in in many
optional and programming languages today
on functional languages too so it's it's
sort of proper what symbol some of us
old people will call a proper block
structure right it's not just about
scoping it's really about being situated
within the the enclosing instances so
good question so so that was similar if
we go and look at what that led to
similar was fairly popular programming
language in industry but not like
broadly wildly successful I think that
it's it's lasting legacy is in what
other languages learned from it so there
- in particular that was sort of the
second generation object-oriented
programming languages one is small talk
which took some of the concepts from
similar and completely
redid them in a in a very very different
kind of context small talk was very
inspired by Lisp which is a not strongly
type at a completely dynamic language
it's also completely reflects reflexive
it can change itself and code is data
and there's no clear separation between
compile-time and run-time in in Lisp and
small talk took all this combined that
with the emerging graphical user
interfaces and produced something that
is a programming language that doesn't
actually even have a full syntax instead
it is this interactive app almost is
this environment that you go into with
Windows and with your with the mouse
that they just invented at Xerox and and
click around and they the all the
programming constructs the classes are
themselves objects running and as your
program you create new classes and put
them into data structures that you can
then view and these and these system
browsers these browsers where you click
around I want to look in that class I
want to see its methods and it's all you
click through lists and only when you
get down to the body of the particular
implementation of a method in a
particular class do you actually the
source code it's a very very different
world and and small talk notably has no
notion of block structure it's all it's
all up in the top layer in fact in many
ways as well a small talk program is
complete spaghetti because the whole
global world is a flat namespace and and
also the there are no control structures
in small talk the only control structure
in small talk in in proper small talk
they cheated a little in some of the
implementations is virtual method calls
right is that's the only thing you have
you don't have if you don't have while
you don't have anything other than
virtual calls and then you have blocks
which are sort of like lambdas and so
the way that you do an if statement
that's an example here is that you take
a bool in and then in boolean expression
and then it has a method called if true
if false then method names are in parts
in between the arguments then you pass
it a block for what did you do if they
do if the object is true and
block for what you do if it's call if
it's false so you can then so there's a
true object in there that implements the
if true if false by calling the the true
argument and there's a false object that
implements the same one by calling the
false argument and that's how that's how
control structures are even even meant
to happen so it's very it's very
consistent and radical and beautiful and
self consistent in its own way but it's
very very different from from the
similar worldview there were some other
people at olives University when Kristen
was there this is actually my dad and he
has nothing to do with his talk other
than he had Kristen I got for his
advisor at and his final project and I
just want to put him in there this is
another guy who was around at the same
time though more people know it's not a
it's not as good of a picture though
this is be honest true strop who came up
with C++ and C pose for us was really
directly inspired not just by similar
but by Kristen when Kristen was there
Donna got to know him
bianna told me how when he was a thesis
student he they had little offices and
the guest apartments for guest lecturers
were just up the stairs at the top floor
of the department and Kristen was there
and he always got bored so he would come
down the stairs looking for something to
do and be honest office would be the
first one he would pass so bianna made
sure to always have a crate of beer in
there so he could lure Kristen to come
in and share a beer and talk about
programming languages and so he was very
personally inspired by these ideas and
opting on in programming but he but he
saw correctly I think a lot of people
have been to writing C++ for like not
being pure and beautiful enough and
making too many compromises but he saw
correctly that it was very hard to
implement these ideas in an efficient
enough manner that there would be broad
adoption of octagon programming so he
wanted to he added it to C which had the
philosophy of kind of no cost
abstractions like no overhead
abstractions and tried to expand that
notion as
as much as was possible to object and
programming and that was really the key
idea of C++ and I have to say wildly
wildly successful right because you got
an option Orion programming language
that was actually competitive today it's
competitive with almost any other
programming language on the planet in
terms of performance now it's been
around for a long time and has many like
aspects that are getting a little long
in the tooth but but it had an amazing
impact and really really contributed to
the success adopting our own programming
had so-so between them the the C++ and
small talk option programming languages
they were the ones that made off your
Orion programming
popular and made it last for 50 years um
so we need to give him credit for that
even though of course Kristin and
Johanna are the real heroes in the story
on that but a lot of things were lost to
a lot of these ideas that Simula had
were lost in that process including the
block structure and the active objects
and the and the inheritance of of code
now I mentioned that Kristin went on to
do Delta which was a language that was
for describing things describing systems
and say even higher level and computers
they couldn't describe things that you
can't couldn't even put in a computer
program and that was sort of a part of a
realization that they had stumbled onto
some really powerful ways of describing
things and and he famously quipped the
sort of a reference to the conceptual
modeling that they that they were
realizing that they were coming up with
that you know one word can say more than
a thousand pictures which is you it's
the other way from how you usually say
it right
one picture can say more than a thousand
words but he turned it on its head
because when you're talking about
abstract concepts like animal for
instance which is what I'm alluding to
here you know it's really hard to draw a
picture of animal what would you draw
right you have you need a thousand
pictures to get the concept across
whereas the word in and of itself has
that whole like expressive power so so
concepts in the language are a very
powerful thing and and basing your
programming language around though
it's a very strong effective thing to do
so they were very focused on modeling
and as he did Delta and as they worked
on beta they kept like honing this
conceptual framework if you will for the
language and and putting a lot of work
into describing in excruciating detail
exactly what it was you did when you're
programmed the program is to understand
it's another phrase that came from that
so there are kind of two layers of this
one is that at the layer of when the
program runs the program execution the
you know you're trying to model
something in the real world or maybe
it's imagined but you're trying to model
something something else and them and
you do that in the computer program but
when you do it you don't model it every
which way it's a it's what they call a
physical model and what that means is
that it's it's one-to-one it you can see
the the things the phenomena in the real
world correspond one-to-one with things
in the model in particular with little
allocated chunks of memory you know that
are the objects every object represents
something that it's modeling and that's
as opposed to how most programming
languages were where maybe you had all
the names in one array and you had all
their all the ages in another array like
the the shape of the of the program as
it was running did not correspond to the
shape of the world that it was trying to
describe whereas that was sort of the
thing that octagon and programming led
to its physical modeling it's one-to-one
and its isomorphic in a sense right you
can think of it that way but also at the
so that's sort of the running program
but at the program text level you sort
of have a similar thing where if you
look at the way that people think about
we're getting to these concepts like the
concepts that people have in their mind
at least so Kristen and others would
claim and it's a fairly it's a
reasonable model for how people think
about things is that they have concepts
in their head they use nouns for them
and some concepts are more special than
others like sheep is more special than
animal
and you know sheep is more special
they're fewer sheep in the world and
they're animals but on the other hand
the sheep have more things together more
things in common they have their more
properties of sheep that are shared
among all sheep then there are
properties that are shared among all
animals right so this is like as you get
more special you have more shared
properties but fewer phenomena that that
fit into the into the concept and that
map's exactly two classes in in object
or new programming languages where you
have that specialization when you create
subclasses so when you prefix like they
said in similar and you add more
properties and more members as you
specialize so that and that
correspondence has been really even
though it was never as clearly expressed
around other program and other
opportunity programming languages that
has been a driving factor I think in how
why they became so popular it's a lot
easier to to conceive and maintain a
system when you when you have this
mental model for a structure that
corresponds to the domain that you're
programming for and it's a lot easier to
involve and get you get participation
from the end users when the concepts of
the program correspond to the concepts
of their domain so um so it's very
powerful
again one-to-one at the at the concept
level there so given that armed with
that realization and lots of red wine
Kristin and his Danish his young Danish
friends they embarked and on beta and
eventually in it's hard to say exactly
when the first beta version was it kept
evolving but around 83 I want to say it
was pretty much finished
they created the programming language to
end all programming languages and so we
tried to really be very true to this to
these modeling ideas but there was also
actually let's let's take a side trip
for a moment just to consider what's
with all these Greek letters actually
there they was Delta and now this beta
well at some point during the red wine
in fuel infused discussions they came up
with this idea that
there were four layers of programming
language of four layers of languages
that were interesting they already had
Delta which was a description language
of the highest level for people only and
then they had high-level programming
languages that you would want to write
programs in but then you needed
implementation languages that where you
sort of had to manually translate to a
low-level program that would run better
on a machine by being implemented in
assembly language which was the lowest
level so by happy coincidence that
mapped just to the sequence of Greek
letters starting with the Delta they
already had and down to the Alpha at the
bottom however so this said the grad
plan was to design all of these
languages one by one but of course the
the lower ones they never got to and the
name beta came to be used for the for
the higher level programming language
turned out they didn't need the lower
ones so that was the origin of those
Greek letters but one central
observation that one thing you noticed
in similar maybe was that this thing
with classes and procedures are very
similar and similar they the thing that
classes can also have code inside and
and so on there there are many ways in
which classes look more like procedures
and similar than they ended up doing in
these other second generation
programming languages whether they
became more different they were sort of
like they cleaned it up and separated
the two concepts probably that's how
they thought of it right but for beta
they kind of they thought about it the
the opposite way they had originally
conceived of objects I think Kristin
said it this way objects are activation
records that survive they're like the
activation records are like the stack
frames right except they're not
necessarily in a stack of a procedure
while it's running like in one
particular instance is running that's
the activation record it looks like an
object right it has some fields which
are the local variables the state of the
of the procedure and essentially the
sort of objects as those guys but they
survive the initial invocation right
they stick around and other people can
refer to them and they and for beta they
thought well isn't it odd that we have
these things that look so much like each
other in the language shouldn't we try
to you know unify shouldn't we try to
see if we can take these two concepts
and smush them together and come up with
one programming language abstraction
single abstraction language where where
we just view procedures and classes as
two different sides of the same coin of
the same construct so so that's what
they did and that's what we're going to
have a look at now so they came up with
this concept called a pattern and
pattern is the unification of classes
and procedures so I have some beta here
and then again you know I have a C like
syntax that I call Sita on the
right-hand side that might make it
easier to read because the beta syntax
is really odd and we'll get into why
part of why it's so odd in a minute but
the idea is so now you can see I have
declarations like before and the things
I'm declaring they look like that
classes like a text stack sounds like a
class link sounds like a class and again
we have the block structure the Kalista
class here but we don't say class
because this is these are pattern
declarations we use the same syntax for
declaring classes and for declaring
procedures it's the same constructs oh
here comes a here comes a non-virtual
method we would we would think of it
today of the of the text stack but it's
really just another pattern it also has
some things you see it has exactly the
same declaration of an element inside as
the link pattern has there they both
have some state inside but then this
also has some other parts than the
declarations namely a a body of code
that it can execute and it also has some
at an equation of what comes out and a
and you can see I tried to map those to
the return keyword over here because
that's sort of more familiar for for C
like syntax if we try to look at a
method that takes things in similar the
push method here another pattern has
some state and it has a do part which is
what it does but it doesn't have an exit
because it doesn't return anything but
it hasn't entered it has parameters
essentially I come in so all patterns
can have all or any of these parts that
they can have declarations they can have
enter parts which are things that come
in they can have a body it is a code
that runs when you execute them and then
an exit part which is what comes out
when you're done executing and now you
can go and build objects or
methods or weird mixtures if you want
out of those to your heart's content
there's no limitation there so that's
sort of the big unification but once
you've done that you have to start
wondering well there were all these
things and simulated that you could only
do for classes or only do for procedures
now I guess we got to have to allow them
for both since they're in the same
they're now the same thing so what
happens when you start allowing these
things across for instance we had
virtual procedures and let me know hang
on before we get there
just let me yeah one of the things was
parameters and and results I get to a
virtual procedures remember we have
parameters and results and procedures we
sort of had parameters for the
Constructors for classes as well but we
didn't have results for when you were
done evaluating a class and similar but
a class like pattern can totally have
have parameters and results you would
use the enter part for for constructing
or initializing it and the exit part is
sort of you can use it for getting the
value evaluating it and and figuring out
what's it made of and for instance if
you want to compare two objects for
equality you don't just want to see if
it's the same object but if they're if
they're equal then you would just
evaluate the the objects and get their
return value out and you compare the
return values so it was used for that
kind of thing now to the virtual
elements well so here we're using it
creating text a creating a text putting
the text in there and getting it out
again no surprises there they a little
hung up on the references they have very
explicit syntax for reference because
objects can also be evaluated so you
need to explicitly take a reference to
the object when you don't want to
evaluate it you just want to pointer
essentially that gets a little tedious
so I just I just alighted that over here
and instead when you want to evaluate an
object I put the parentheses on the end
like you're calling it that's probably
more familiar today so but it's a text
stack what if I wanted a stack of that a
generic stack stack of anything can you
somehow do generics in in in beta well
yes you can because you can
and this comes to the thing about what
what's this class what's the thing with
classes that corresponds to virtual
methods well that should be virtual
classes what is a virtual class well
it's a class declaration inside of
another class that can be overwritten
and derive classes and so here for
instance I am declaring a class a
virtual class called type which is the
type of thing that this stack is
supposed to hold and then if I want to
create a stack of a particular type then
I prefix I derive from and make a
subclass of the Oh should have just said
stack here and that's a typo of stack
and and I overwrite the the class here
and now I have a stack of texts because
all the places because now inside of
this particular stack everything
everywhere it's this type in the code
that now means text just like a generic
parameter of a type parameter right but
I but instead of passing it in through a
parameter list I pass it in by
specializing you use inheritance a lot
more so that's one way that that's one
kind of crossover concept that almost
didn't catch on anywhere except actually
in Scala they have this notion of
abstract type which is exactly this they
this is probably the only really useful
concept from beta that survived into
another I wouldn't say Skylar's
mainstream but at least another language
that's alive and well it got the the
abstract types which are virtual
essentially virtual classes from beta
and I actually think it's a wonderful
concept and I would love to have them in
c-sharp one day so other things you can
as you saw also in no actually not as
you saw in them a similar to what you
saw in Simula you can also create
procedure patterns that can be
specialized that you can derive from so
you can have a base pattern that is a
procedure so this is for each that will
enumerate all the elements in the in the
data structure and and invoke some code
for each of
today you would probably in other
languages you do that by passing in a
lambda for the code to invoke but not
here
what you do instead is you leave an
inner in the for each and then people
can go and create a sup procedure of by
deriving from for each putting code into
the inner like their code goes into the
inner and and now when you when you run
that one as the loop goes around your
code gets executed every time right so
so you don't need to necessarily look at
the details but it's just a loop that
has a little you know it has it keeps
track of how far you are down the list
it puts an element type in an element in
scope that the inner can use and it also
has a bool that you can set to true if
you want to end if you want to terminate
the loop okay so if inner assigns true
to to end then the next time around the
while loop quits so let's look at a use
of that here's this very simple use of
for each I'm creating another method
inside of stack that's the count method
to tells you how many elements are in
here it derives from for each it gets
all this code and it adds another member
in there which is the size that we're
counting into the accumulator and then
it runs this code every time around so
it count it ups the counter and then it
adds a return which which is the the
sizes it as it is at the end right so so
it's very you don't really need lambdas
in a language like this you can you you
you specialize instead of passing
lambdas or or higher-order parameters
another example is a contains method
that checks whether a given object is
contained in here well how do we know
when an object is the same that may
depend on what element type we have how
should they be compared so we can put a
virtual method on the stack class that
is a virtual pattern that the does the
comparison and then when you create your
own stack class and you override the
type you also override the equals
message to say when should we consider
two objects equal and but you can't
override in the same way that you could
in Sumy land that
you can in in any other of your and
programming languages because it's not
conceptually pure to take if something
is in the general class it should stay
there you can't concept should be more
special so this shouldn't be able to
throw things away from the more general
concepts that should only be able to
extend them so in beta you can't
override what you do instead is you
specialize the method so we saw how you
can inherit from one method to another
and that and that's what you have to do
also when you have a virtual method the
the override essentially implicitly
inherits from the original declaration
so again we have something here that
doesn't do much it has a pool but it
doesn't do anything with it instead it
has an inner and people will overwrite
the equals method can then provide the
body that does the actual comparison and
assigns the result into the result
variable here another interesting way of
using virtual patterns so we so now we
have virtual patterns both virtual
classes and virtual procedures but
another thing that in similar you can
only have virtual members in classes you
can't have them in procedures but in
beta for because of generality you can
have virtual methods inside of other
methods so the so the fine method
specializes for each adds aware virtual
method that you use to provide a
condition to the find method that you
need to satisfy in order to be found by
the fine method
alright so that's an again an abstract
method that returns a boolean and
somebody who uses to find method they
start out by creating a sub a sub class
a sub procedure that specializes the
where method to do the actual comparison
and then you run it and and that's what
it does as it goes down the chain as it
reaches this kind of combines it all
together so just to say very very
beautiful conceptual generalization
probably a little too abstract for most
people so I didn't nothing really came
of it as for the why is beta syntax so
odd Kristin really liked
hanging out and when he came to ojos he
was off to visit which he kept doing
also when I was a student and I met him
many times he was often bored and he
wanted to go out and have fun but you
know there was a particular day when all
the all his own old students were busy
with their kids and the only people who
could go out with him was me and one of
my fellow students was also called
Kristen so we went to Cafe Casablanca in
Ho Hos and we got drunk and Kristen
started explaining why bata had the
syntax it had essentially they had had
this idea that it's easier to learn a
programming language if all the if all
the constructs are described with words
but it gets tedious to use a programming
language when you're when you become
proficient on your professional
developer so you want to have short
little squiggles like in C C's very
terse has very few words keywords and so
they wanted to say well I want to give
you a choice every construct has two
syntaxes that has a word syntax and a
glyph syntax okay that was the idea for
beta and they designed it all out and
that design he actually wrote down on
the paper tablecloth where we were
sitting in the bar and drinking and and
I later just almost like the day after I
woke up and I went and talked to my
buddy Christ thing we're like why did we
not keep the the tablecloth why didn't
we bring it with us after when we went
home we were too drunk to think of it
imagine having that tablecloths a day
and it had like all Kristin
scribbles specifically you know
especially for us that would have been
cool and we didn't do it anyway so
looking further into the future of
course the next generation of optic
learning programming languages there was
an object Pascal slash turbo Pascal
slash Delphi and as Hollis Berg was
involved in most of those an
implementation of them and there was
Java of course which is the big big
thing that came out of some weird
marriage between small talk and C++ that
turned out surprisingly
they they were really basing Java off a
small talk
James Gosling has talked about this
sense that it was they like this very
dynamic thing and Java has reflection
and all that and has a strong runtime
representation of object of classes
which C++ doesn't it it races it all
like compile time but they wanted it to
be excessive they wanted to be strongly
typed and they wanted even strong more
strongly typed than C++ which doesn't
say a lot and they wanted it to be
accessible to people so they stole all
the C syntax and C++ syntax and that was
essentially how Java came about and of
course it was wildly wildly successful
and also derived from small talk where's
a bunch of scripting languages Python
Ruby and the several of them I just put
Python here that became very successful
Python is now in the Stack Overflow
survey this year I think it's a the
fourth most popular language because of
its use in a science community that's
now turning into data science code all
over a very very obscure route where
they took small talk and ripped out the
classes and only left objects so if you
wanted to make new objects you just had
to create them from scratch or clone
them from other objects it's called
prototype based programming and that
would have remained obscure if it wasn't
for Java Script that became in the three
weeks that it was written it was
inspired by all of these Java from this
for the syntax and this it was a
scripting language inspired by Python
and it had this prototype based objects
idea that was built-in so now everybody
the most popular programming language in
the world now uses has only recently
gotten classes classes isn't even up
until now wasn't even a thing and this
supposedly opticore in programming
language so that was sort of the and of
course the story goes on but they want
only one thing I also want to mention is
that yes somewhere in there the c-sharp
which was you know mildly inspired by
Java and to to make a joke of it and and
of course by others as well including we
reinstating some C++ concepts so that's
kind of how it all play out but there is
beta all alone with no arrows going out
from it nobody really actually ever used
it for anything
no no one adopted it Industrial II for
long and it and not many of the ideas
made it except for the virtual classes
that I mentioned before made it to other
other languages so it was kind of like
in a sense it was a it wasn't the
success that similar was I didn't have
the impact or the usage but but from an
academic point of view it's a really
wonderful thing to study and it kind of
reminds us that you know sometimes it's
one of those languages like self
actually also I love self and beta
because they're languages that take a
concept and they go all away with it and
it's very not just mind blowing but mind
expanding to sometimes go and learn and
maybe use those languages and think
about wow wow the world look really
looks different from this place it's
kind of like fundamentalism it makes the
world it makes it a lot easier to
interpret everything in the world
Kristen was very loved and well known in
the in the programming community I
happened to I arranged a programming
language conference about five years ago
and we had a we had a party and some of
my speakers were older than the rest and
sort of a they were catching up from old
days this is a be honest rooster who was
the keynote speaker there and we have we
have Dave Unger who was the the primary
designer of self that I showed before we
have will cook who's also influenced
programming languages over the years and
they were kind of sitting for themselves
in a four-person booths and I'm walking
around being the organizer checking in
on people and I there are these three
old guys and creaky knee guys I'm like
and I get you guys something can I fetch
a beer for you whatever and they're like
hey Matt we were just exchanging stories
about Kristin Durgan
do you want to sit down and join us and
they pointed to the fourth empty scene I
was like I'm in heaven I'm in heaven I
get to sit and talk to these old guys
about Kristin egor they were all just
like they all had different stories they
interacted with them in different
periods of time and and we just all like
touched by him it's kind of impressive
that it's not just the technology it's
really also the person really really it
touched a lot of people they're so happy
to have known him a little
and had that experience his final a lot
of people now if you go and read his the
the eulogies and so on for Kristen a lot
of people reference his last public talk
that I was also at which was a banquet
speech at the Eco conference in Malaga
in 2002 as it turned out only a few
months before he died of a heart attack
and a few months before uh Leo Han Dahl
died he was actually sick at the time
and we signed a giant big get well card
for him unfortunately that wasn't enough
and he gave this fun speech that many
people remember and I particularly it
was like hilarious he was so so funny
and and one of the things that he he
took offense to was that Danes have this
weed I just just to make it clear if it
isn't already we Dame's make a lot of
fun we took a lot of fun at Norwegians
and you know we it's all unfounded but
particularly have this notion we have
this term called fair labor which is
Mountain monkeys right and that's that
just means no agents I'm sorry but it's
slang for Norwegians and he picked up on
this and he was mildly offended by it
and he said well well no it wasn't true
but it was fun like in no way we call
Dame's plane monkeys ambiguity intended
and I thought that was kind of that was
kind of neat so yeah I think that the
only thing left is to think about well
what what was some of the things that
also maybe came in from the beginning
with optical and programming but maybe
weren't so good and then we can talk a
little bit about the future so this
conceptual model thing as a model as
reasoning for why the languages to sign
the way it is it's all fair and good but
sometimes we have to be honest and say
well there are the languages could have
looked looked a lot different and still
fit the conceptual framework that they
came up with there was some things in
particular that weren't in the language
that weren't there because the
conceptual look at the concept said that
there should be but they were there
because it was for computers and we
couldn't figure out how to do it
otherwise right one of them single
inheritance
right so concepts can totally overlap
you can have overlapping concept right
you gave you can have a in Denmark we
have all these proofs of owner that you
have a mobile sausage stand right so
it's both a vehicle and it's a and it's
an eatery right okay so it's overlapping
concepts and you have that all over it's
easy to run into that in real life so
it's not like neat hierarchies it's a
web right there
this definitely specialization and
generalization it's an ordered graph but
it's not and it's not cyclic but it but
it's also not just a hierarchy right
it's not um it's not a tree so
object-oriented programming has
struggled with this ever since like for
these 50 years there's been this uneasy
thing about should you have multiple
inheritance then C++ has multiple
inheritance other languages do but it
gets really ugly because translating
that into something that's beautiful at
a language level and it and efficient
and easy to reason about turned out to
be surprisingly hard and so we've landed
now on this uneasy compromise in the
statically typed languages that we have
interfaces which are not classes but
they're very like classes but they don't
have code in them and so they don't have
the technical problems that you have
when you try to combine different
concepts so you can have all your
concept overlap that you want at the
interface level once you get to classes
you have to choose what's the main
hierarchy and then do that in classes
and it's not beautiful you know it's
it's not economical to have these two
different kinds of types but it's the
way we could figure out how to do it a
big one I want to say is the the
singularity the the null reference
exceptions
so I mentioned Tony Hoare invented the
reference the referenced record types
and invented the null reference because
it was easy that's like okay that could
be null because that's there and then we
had now we have an initial value for
them and and everyone's happy and off to
the races
and and he calls it his billion dollar
mistake and gives talks about that
like and
we never really came to grips of that
null null reference exceptions are not
just enough to go in programming
language but they're worse because
everything is a referee things by
reference so you have them all the time
and also most optical and programming
languages are strongly imperative and so
UN so the way that you the way that an
object starts out it starts out with its
fields having all the default values and
then you have to initialize it before
before it should be observed but people
can typically observe objects before
they're fully initialized or they forget
to initialize something and these
default values leak out so there there's
a lot of risk of null and by the way
null isn't bad right null is a very
useful thing for expressing okay
something I didn't have that I didn't
have that value or it only sometimes
there or whatever like it's a
semantically useful thing and what Tony
Hoare said was he should just have
introduced a notion in the type system
where you could declare whether the null
was okay or not like if you've done that
said there's there's nullable none novel
references then you wouldn't have had
this problem with null reference
exceptions because then the type system
could tell you when you were doing the
right thing and when you weren't and we
sort of only slowly coming to grips with
that now some of the modern programming
languages are a lot better at dealing
with nulls we're trying to add something
to c-sharp novel reference types that
let you distinguish between whether
whether object references should be
should be null or not and if they
shouldn't then we can say don't stick a
null in there and give you a warning and
if they should then we'll let you do it
but then when you do reference we say
hey you forgot to check for null before
you dereference and we can catch you
there and help reduce the null reference
exceptions which are really like a I
think of it a little bit like fossil
fuels
fuels right in that the fossil fuels
really help civilize give civilization a
boost and we grew our economy and our
science and everything a lot more
quickly because of fossil fuels but we
also paid a high price that now we have
to learn how to how to get along without
it and I think null was one of those
things that it was one of those
shortcuts to greatness that we were sort
of all just ignoring the elephant in a
room for a while and and well we can't
keep doing that
so looking for the next 50 50 years from
now somebody can use the zero send 100
for an oo joke if they want to if
they're still after you going
programming around you know the pennies
for for every object and it might be
good to take a temperature on house up
you're going to programming doing now
you obviously it's wildly successful you
have to go pretty far down the list of
most used languages before you get to
one that's not object-oriented so
obviously it has succeeded wildly in a
certain sense but it's also the object
oriented paradigm is struggling to deal
with some of the modern challenges in
programming in particular it's sort of
very it's very fine grained on state
right it says that everything I know
about sheep should be in the Sheep class
everything I know about sheep not just
what data is in they are used to to
track the Sheep but also all the
functionality that they have it will be
in virtual methods and when I want to do
something that's particular to every
animal the way I do it is that I put a
virtual method in animal and I override
it and it's all - it's all together Salk
and capsulated together and that's great
if you're only describing if you're only
using sheep for one kind of program
right and if you're doing it locally and
you can track all the state and so on
but both sort of at a program level and
also at the program execution level to
go to those two levels again we're now
in a much more distributed world you
have libraries of data and you have
libraries and you have actual data that
gets used from many different programs
and also on many different computers at
the same time like the the shapes get
used in many different programs and the
data get used on many different machines
so this all this distribution that kind
of tears against the encapsulation of
opticon in programming and so I think
that I think functional programming has
answers to all of that but they but they
suck in other ways like they're they
lack a lot of the goodness of optimum
programming and I think that the the
trend that we've been seeing now
for the last it's it started about a
decade ago I think with the programming
language Scala is to try to bring
object-oriented and functional
programming together and try to look for
instead of viewing them as we did in the
old days certainly as as Kristin's age
did as being like fundamentally
different and completely separate
paradigms we should try to look for
commonalities and in which ways are
object-oriented and functional
programming actually the same or very
compatible and try to bring them
together into a unified paradigm that
sometimes has two different ways of
doing things but they're complementary
rather than competing right I think
Scala did a good first whack at that it
was the first language that had that as
a philosophy from the start saying we
want to create a language that is
equally an object and a functional
programming language but not in that it
just smooshes all the features on both
in but it tries to sync them together
tries to unify them like beta try to
unify classes and procedures they try to
unify the two paradigms and I think
that's a good I don't agree with
everything they do in Scala by far in
the specifics but I think that's a great
philosophy and I and having started out
in c-sharp with an object-oriented
programming language
people sometimes accuse me of you know
they don't quite dare to do that but
they sometimes sort of imply that we
were like blinded by functional
programming and we don't like up your
programming anymore but we're really
trying to import good ideas from
functional programming into c-sharp in a
way that complements and works well with
what's already there and create sort of
like this combined world where you can
use the right tools for the job and on
both sides so that's sort of like that's
I think a trend that we'll see play out
over the next decade and and have
languages that are a lot less pure one
of you the other of course may be some
new ideas may come out or new turns may
happen in the world that obviate all
that and something new will happen I
can't look 50 years out in the future
but that's the that's the change that I
I'm seeing now that's been ongoing for a
while and I think it's going to hit the
mainstream
over there over the next decade or so
it's going to become mainstream as the
the current big languages try to adapt
to this and it may be that we get
replaced by some that do it better
because they do it from the beginning
maybe the dispels the death of c-sharp
and Java and all that but we try not to
we try to we try to be part of that
movement and and do a good job of
embracing it so that puts us at the end
of the talk yeah I'll take questions and
hang out for bed a few rightwell options
sort of solve the problem if you if
that's all you have from the start then
it becomes a lot better they saw part of
the problem then in that you don't have
any other mechanisms you in the problem
is that in our current languages we
already have decoupled the checking of
null from the dereferencing right so you
can forget to do one and still do the
other if you if you start with option
types the way you get at the what's
inside is some sort of pattern matching
where you can't get the value inside
without also checking for null at the
same time so it's sort of like by
construction impossible to get a null
reference exception however what you're
not solving is what's for when you don't
have an option type when you have
something that's just a reference and
you know it never to be null you want it
to never be known what's its default
value yes and that you have to assign it
that is very hard to enforce
it's barely possible to enforce in a
functional world where you don't
typically have subtyping and overriding
and and chaining constructors and all
that in an object joinder world getting
all that toothpaste back in the tube and
making sure that nobody ever forgets to
assign to an unknowable thing that is in
practice extremely hard to do it may be
that we make
sign progress enough I'd love for that
to be the case that we actually can get
there and say okay we've got this solved
now this was that turned out to be the
way to do it but we're not quite there
yet it's but Swift has problems where
you you get into the corners and you
still struggle with the default value
stuff it's they pushed it pretty far to
the corners and it's pretty impressive
what they did and they could do that
because they start out fresh with a new
language but they still have problems to
the extent that they're object-oriented
it's very it's extremely hard and you
know languages are messy we have we also
have static constructors and we have and
when you have constructors you can call
virtual methods on the object that
you're in and that even though it's not
initialized and there all this stuff
that's just chasing down all that to
make sure that you never ever observe an
unknowable reference before it's been
assigned is well in our current
languages it's impossible it's just it's
just too incomplete right it can't be
done but in the general but we may be
able to have languages where we can
button it down enough without
lobotomizing it to the point where it's
not usable anymore finding that balance
I think it's an open question still and
we're making great but we're making all
trying to make strides at it from
different angles and that's why I think
it's totally conceivable that we'll find
the right balance and that new
programming languages five years from
now will no longer have this problem
that we awesome of course we still well
we can't can't get rid of in c-sharp for
instance but they do it better but
that's because there's Explorer that's
because of the aspect of being a
functional programming language that is
that there are a lot of things you can't
do in them yeah they button you down
quite hard right in some function of
program language you can't even reassign
things right they're all things are
immutable they trend heavily towards
immutable and they're just some kinds of
abstraction that are not there so it
kind of yes you can most of the time
if you don't want all these other good
features that's the problem and some
people are happy just living in a
functional world well more power to them
they don't have the null problem and
they can be very arrogant about it we
don't have that problem over here
anymore and you guys you you know but
but the truth of the matter is that they
that's a lot of expressiveness that they
leave on the table like that so yeah if
we can solve it in that hybrid world
where functional and off you're gonna
die coming together that will be that
will be fabulous I would love a future
that it has that how and the way that's
good way of putting it yeah the how and
the what maybe yeah but yeah yeah you
kind of have to again you have to strike
a balance
nobody is particularly in love with
having to say how all the time right and
that's part of why people love
functional programming is you can but
you often end up saying how anyway you
just say differently there's still
nitty-gritty you never get away from the
nitty-gritty but yeah we'll see where it
goes but I think I'm optimistic about I
really like I like the programming
language scene right now I like that we
are not monopolies with the big
languages but that there are lots of
smaller very forward-looking creative
languages that are actually thriving
industrially as well I think it pushes
us all it pushes up the velocity of
innovation in programming languages in a
good good way so yeah I'm really happy
about that it's um
that's the right way it was a bit boring
for some years there were Java was kind
of sitting on everything
I went to was researcher at the time I
went to research conferences and all the
research papers was essentially the
title of all the papers was doing what
we did the last time we published a
paper but now in Java right as all
reheated stuff trying to everyone try to
get on the Java bandwagon it was amazing
how much error took out of the room that
was not a good environment
I mean Java is good in many ways but
there was just not a good environment
where nothing else could could thrive so
it's much better now there I I don't
mind the competition I welcome it if
like we're we're all in this in this
quest together to make programming
better cool thanks for coming y'all yeah
it was not as big as the first one but
it is it's fun there's more fun in a
different way this way thanks for
sticking with me thank you